when you physically patch your hands are
on the signal in a very special way we
can make any sound we want it's
extremely flexible in terms of
controlling creating sound but the whole
act of working with the medium you're
really losing touch with the physical
world I think we've lost that in digital
synthesis hi I'm Joe Pardy so I'm
professor here at the MIT Media Lab
where I run the responsive environments
group we tend to look at new kinds of
sensor technology and how it connects to
people in different ways when I was an
undergraduate in 1975 I started building
what was probably the world's largest
modular synthesizer at least over the
course of in the next decade
one of the beautiful things about
modular sense I think is that they don't
do anything when you turn them all on
there's no predefined hookup you have to
put it in yourself so it forces you to
be creative to really try to think of
something new because you're starting
with nothing I love the idea sounds
coming from different sources they're
almost like little creatures that kind
of appear they pop their hand out they
do their thing
it may be affected by other things
around them and they go back down into
that hole the ways they do that is very
much a whole part of making a patch yeah
listenable and evolve and not be born
when I first work in the patch if I were
going too fast to have to get to a place
where it is just too cacophonous and is
too much happening there once but then I
pull it back a little bit
that can transform to something
wonderful
I can control the probability of when
the sound is going to come with a logic
ever since I can remember music was
critically important to me even as a kid
I was doing a lot of tape loop
experiments and just playing with sound
before I had the synthesizer my dad was
a photographer videographer it might
Arashi an MIT and we can laugh but you
also love to build things I'd sit with
him and he'd show me what he was doing
and taught me a lot I learned to solder
when I was in the early elementary
school and start from wiring up my own
things I was very influenced by the
instrument pioneers of the 60s and Bart
mogh and Dom booklet come to mind right
away I got to know them both toward the
last bit of their lives and wonderful
people very inspirational very
unassuming to Bob built an instrument
that could be played we could bring
different kinds of sounds together with
patching and be able to create lots of
things that people had never heard
before
[Music]
and then of course I got into prog rock
when it started coming out another
impetus to build a synthesizer because
that was the vocabulary of prog rock in
anyways I would see these pictures on
record covers I would hear these
wonderful sounds could never afford to
buy one
they were Titanic expensive benefit so I
had to build one by the time the early
70s came about there I was starting to
put it together but then a post-doctoral
creel I don't know anybody here what do
I do
oh I should start building synthesizer
modules I've got all these ideas I did
the MIT style thing of working in the
lab for a night and day trying to get my
work ahead for the first year or so I
took a casio VL tone and took it apart
and built a whole structure around that
with a full-size keyboard and then it
started building modules at the end I
had 70 modules so my life just was
obsessed by building modules so I came
back from Zurich I do other things but I
didn't neglect the scent we're creative
to survive sometimes so I used
creativity to keep going the synthesizer
is located at MIT plasma science and
fusion center doing work in science and
working with data you often times wonder
what it sounds like I approach the
physicist at the fusion center I said
well look can you give us some of this
data and then we can take it and try to
use it in the past my student converted
it into WAV files and I edited them and
I found all kinds of things some of some
of the stuff isn't very creepy I mean if
you take data and listen to it in
different ways they can sound almost
alive like some weird life form or sound
of an alien cockpit or something like my
students yeah they want to be involved
and they came up with the idea not just
of streaming it which is great but of
trying to let people control it over the
web
I'm joining a modular that way is weird
people loved it that suddenly it started
passing around the world so we had
40,000 users over the span of some some
week controlling the synthesizer was a
great thing to see I think this is a
rich palette for the future artists
right data is their new palette the
future of music is fascinating as it's
changing so fast music is a shortcut to
the emotion in many ways and you know
you can see it see things in music right
you can experience things you even the
whole stories come it's like reading a
great book it's humans start to
generalize a bit more as our brain
starts to move outside of our head which
is kind of what's happening right
because we're offloading so much already
to the cloud with our handheld devices
is we get wearables that would be much
more and once we have implantables
eventually and you look far enough ahead
that's one of the main futures this is
all going to change a musical chain if
you look at modular as an AI and new
ways of interacting with computers it's
that whole essence of patching and that
whole dialogue you have with a physical
system that I think is rich and that can
be extracted digitally in ways that we
haven't thought of